if somebody from the outside is telling
me you can't do or you shouldn't do I'm
like [ __ ] you I'ma Do It Like I know
that about myself so I have to look I
know that I have to learn the hard way
that's just me it's an individual but
once I learn I'm like you're not gonna
fool me again I'm not gonna go through
that again because I'm also a learner so
yeah
um if somebody from the outside could
have seen it would have been great if
they told me I probably still wouldn't
listen because I'm a hard-headed
individual so this is one of the
comments the reason it's six to seven
years is that's about how long women can
quote unquote live a lie before they
have it to unburden themselves with the
torture of the lie that they don't
actually want the man they're with
probably that's what they said the thing
is the things that I've learned as a man
and being in a relationship like that
for me are they're priceless
for me dude I'm just saying for me that
that I absolutely Priceless would you do
it again hell no like I wouldn't because
I'm smarter now that's the thing